hey guys i'm ryan right and i am jerry
so we're gonna watch the trailer for a
movie that i have very minimal
anticipation on for some reason san
andreas the rocks new movie ok my mind
went straight degree have daughter yeah
I think it's an earthquake film positive
and uplifting let's watch it let's watch
let's watch the rock save us from
earthquakes punch there's a quick flash
there
[Music]
where will you be
you be loved I who will you keep well I
had the winter gable things oh it's her
she's going when everything goes to [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
you need to get out
[Music]
because even though is this happening
here in California
you will feel it on the East Coast
[Music]
[Music]
hello and trailers take up that is a
lovely song and make it all dark that is
literally every trailer like it looks
intense like I'm not gonna I was kind of
disturbed because that's all like ten
minutes away from us and please so close
this is the thing I've learned about
movies is that aliens hate New York
but mother nature hates Los Angeles yeah
anytime weather is destroying [ __ ] they
always make sure to include LA what's
neat about it is rather than being like
every other role in emmerich film where
it's going around the whole globe is
this a role in every film no it's not
but it looks like it was like a role in
every group they're primarily just
focused on destroying California though
they say like it'll reach the East Coast
and they got Paul Giamatti in there and
who I'm sure will make everything more
intense Paul Giamatti M it sounds just
like my Joker Paul Giamatti I mean like
it looks cool it looks thrilling this
looks like one of those movies it's
gonna be like 2 hours and 40 minutes
when it should have been like an hour
and 40 I mean it sounds like it's gonna
do exactly what all these disaster
movies do now instead of focusing on a
lot of different people it's like you're
gonna focus on this one guy so it feels
so personal this is just world war with
their earthquake World War Z war the
world yeah like they focus on one person
well this you shits going on so you're
personally invested which tends to work
but he's probably like a struggling
family man yeah there's probably his
daughter who he doesn't get along with
and now he has to find redemption yeah
he has to use his like ex-military
helicopters
he has to save every but all these kinds
of movies are about former or aspiring
military people
it does look creepier and more menacing
than I mean 10 a lot of these like
roland emmerich movie teasing them
forgive me cuz i was chuckling the whole
time because it is an effective trailer
formula like quiet shot of something
really big and heavy in scope and then
like broken up phrases and then oh here
comes the really serene and very like
gravitas heavy cover of a popular song
you know Oh crazy destruction but it's
really quiet and then the one like
heavyweight actor we've
how manners just to get as a supporting
character says something about how
intense this all is cut to the title as
it like turns around
it's the Godzilla trailer in the Ninja
Turtles yeah yeah transformers trailers
and like various superhero movie
trailers I think it works like it looks
cool yeah it looks cool I mean I'm not
all that intrigued by it though I was
getting depressed and like shocked
only because literally it's like right
down the street from us so it was
scaring the [ __ ] out of me for the
moment but then I would get back into
them like [ __ ] rock the rocks right
there man when I feel back it's like I'm
trying not to get jaded about these
movies though cuz like some shots I'm
like well it looks really great like
when the Hollywood sign is falling down
like wow I look so crazy and then when
they cut to the giant like chasm I'm
like looks like CG yeah and then there's
like really good CG and then there are
shots where like when the building's
flying over the helicopter is a [ __ ]
amazing venture you just go back like
wow you're handling skills even though
you haven't been I assume in the army
for a long time it looks a little
typical but I mean sure people are gonna
go for life exciting disaster yeah I
feel like it'll deliver on what people
want from it no I'm just gonna bury my
face in a bag of popcorn and you know
move my fist every now and again as the
rock punches buildings there's other
pieces of debris in the face and you
know the rock is really evolved since
like the Scorpion King this is the new
scorpy this isn't youth this is what's
gonna redefine it at the very end of
this movie I just wanted to come out
dressed at the squirrel feet see what
they should have done is make this movie
and then get the rock for the sequel ah
anyway guys thanks for telling me that
trailer is out yeah it looks like it'll
deliver on what you want yeah it looks
like it's gonna do exactly what its
gonna do if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
take out Jerry's show reasons to Jerry
doesn't move your reviews while driving
do which has pissed off a few people
does that's a dangerous man you
shouldn't do that
Vincente Shran hey Rio rejects my name
is Vincent ran and I'm the director of
Batgirl rises cool Batgirl Rises we
premiered at Universal Studios Hollywood
whoa October 24 2014 is scheduled to
launch on the 2015 comic-con film
festival circuit would love to
collaborate he wants to collaborate with
us yeah he's gonna make Ryan Wright
rises looking forward to your response I
Navy will collaborate oh I have to act
like I have the upper hand granted and
film show at Universal and it's gonna be
a comic-con but I gotta put this guy and
you gotta make it seem like you don't
give a [ __ ] a little better raises you
got to write a book about this someday I
will like it you're like a brilliant
business mind it'll be called
interstellar - you're like Ryan Rice's
check out Batgirl Rises Ben page whoo I
only found this channel a few days ago
but goddamn man I've watched like 15 of
your videos already ha ha yep call me
crazy
no no that helps out with views thank
you but I think your channels total gold
I know great guest stars yeah all right
genuine laughs huh oh sure and it's
obvious that you know your [ __ ] when it
comes to movies it really just takes
like 2 or 3 facts and people think you
know you're talking about keep up the
great work
PS if you do in fact see this comment
you'll be surprised you ready for this
home - no I'm gonna turn the tables on
you and give you a shout-out in an
upcoming video will I continue in V&S
series you just turned it around he
turned it around this is like a very
surprise filled shout out session well
Ben Paige your vns series is so cool I
like it so much i watch it I've seen it
before so excited to get a shout out on
it I should check it out
what is it series I don't know what the
[ __ ] of me in a series we should check
it out then pay if we're gonna check
your [ __ ] out vaginas
I want necrophiliac semen it's a vagina
necrophiliac semen series fan page check
it out check open pages check well
thanks for the shoutout
that's awesome man Anthony are Ivalo
what's up Ryan your videos are amazing
give me a shout-out keep up the awesome
videos they're hilarious more Alyssa be
crazy miss her boobs a lot of
subscribers are just a don't like this
they love the channel but they're kind
of degrading to the woman on the shadow
just a little bit I wonder where they
got that from theythey think you can
just get away with making jokes like
that
I mean Alyssa's boobs I never seen them
but I'm sure they're great he says our
videos aren't hilarious
that is the word to describe our videos
we don't set out to be fun
no she just happens it's just happens we
just want respect for our opinions we
want to be known for our knowledge not
for the silliness not for the out off
banter crap that we do not for the
amount of times people have clicked
Ryan's dick yeah to subscribe that's
right the dick lift isn't about this
little trailer he's gonna shout out all
over ya shoutout